hidden in the world of Super Mario
Odyssey are war paintings that will take
you to secret locations in other
kingdoms and reward you with a power
moon if you're going after all the moons
you'll need to find all ten but before
we get started I will warn you stay
clear of this video until you finish the
game if you don't want any spoilers for
future kingdoms or costumes if however
you finish the story and want to find
all those sneaky hidden war paintings
then stay tuned the first painting is in
the cascade Kingdom right the start of
the level follow the path around the
waterfall and in true video game cliches
there is always something hidden behind
waterfalls to find them painting in the
sand kingdom simply walk to tossed arena
ruins sand pillar once there turn right
spot pillar next to the jacksie stop
head on down and the picture frame will
be hiding behind the stone column to get
the painting in the wooden kingdom
you'll need to do a little platforming
walk to iron mountain path station 8 and
once there jump down the railings follow
the yellow pole bounce your way across
the destructible platforms and throw
your hat at the Scarecrow jump across
the time of challenge blocks and grab
the moon if you haven't already and if
you've managed not to fall off then keep
walking across the girder to find the
painting behind the metal cube the
painting in the lake Kingdom is nice and
easy just warp to the courtyard flag and
jump in the nearby pool and extra points
if you manage to do a sick flip Metro
kingdoms painting is also super easy to
find it's right under your nose well
right under your ship when you land go
behind your ship jump onto the platform
and there it is
the snow kingdom painting is a little
trickier take control the cloud that's
down the path from your ship and head to
the northeastern section of the map you
use the cloud ability to blow the large
wooden block over to the platform once
it's over as far as it'll go just jump
out of the cloud heading up the
platforms and there's the painting the
seaside Kingdom is also an easy one you
just have to beat the boss first when
you leave your ship jump into one of the
water spouts and you'll be fired onto a
platform under which the painting is
hiding swim on down and claim your prize
[Music]
the luncheon kingdom painting takes a
little exploring head on over to the
path to the meat plateau and find
yourself a lava bubble you want to head
to the island to the northeast of the
map and you'll need one of these lava
boys to get there also make sure you get
hit by a pepper that's very important at
the back of the island you'll find you
guessed it another painting once he
returns the Bowser Kingdom warped the
main courtyard entrance once there take
a left and hop over the railing head
behind the building and hey presto your
ninth painting finally for the last
painting heads the ever peaceful
Mushroom Kingdom
super easy to find with your back to the
ship turn right and between these two
trees is your final piece of art so
that's where all the paintings are
hidden hopefully this will help you get
every Power moon in the game but if you
want to see some more secrets that make
sure you keep your eyes and game spot we
have some more cool guides coming very
soon
[Music]